why am I the one talking about this
what's simple I was the best person for
the part no other people weren't
considered why that matter lgbtq+ topic
time sponsored this time around by
Skillshare so I'm due to poke and pick
at another rhetorical argument that I
see often enough in my own comment
section that I want to put my thoughts
on the record and then just move on from
it so I have come at the topic of
casting cisgender actors in the roles of
transgender characters a few times
already and one of the things that
people feel that I am wrong in my
assertions about that topic do tend to
claim is that the SIS actors in question
were right to play these roles because
they were quote the best for the part
now I'm going to be focusing this
conversation as it applies to trans
character casting but it's an argument
that also gets deployed on the topics of
racial recasting or casting an
able-bodied person in a disabled role or
even aging characters up significantly
or down significantly so what I'm going
to say would actually apply in other
similar circumstances part one your
patron get wrong I've already addressed
the question of why trans actors should
be cast in trans roles so if you need to
you can check out that video if you
don't already know where I'm coming from
on that issue which you might want to do
because I am NOT going to reiterate
those points here we are going to be
taking it as read and just dealing with
the best for the role argument on its
own as is often the case with these
things it is nearly impossible to be
sure whether someone is deploying this
argument in good faith in which case
they might genuinely believe that this
is how casting works or in bad faith
using it as a thought terminating cliche
intended to simply
and the discussion but as I've done in
more than a few instances now I'm going
to address it in good faith in the hope
that those who aren't just expressing it
solely as a debate tactic might benefit
from some nuance there is basically one
massive glaring problem with the best
person for the role of defense it
presumes that there was a casting
process where these cysts actor who was
cast beat out other candidates by giving
the best audition and simply put that is
not how this works not even a little bit
and ask someone who went to more than a
few auditions when I was trying to break
into film and stage acting oh boy once
upon a time I actually get to talk from
experience as well as the research that
I did into the topic now if you think
that the audition queue for any given
part looks like this well we've got some
serious bubble bursting to do so strap
in because wow this is wonderfully
egalitarian it's not in the least bit
practical and pretty much doesn't happen
truly open auditions are barely a thing
at all and they are soo poor not a thing
when it comes to lead roles in
mainstream films actual indie films as
opposed to indie in quotes where it's
just a major director and star deciding
to make the movie for under 10 million
dollars those truly indie films might
have something closer to that scene I
showed you but legitimately independent
productions aren't what we're talking
about here and they've also been way
more likely to cast trans actors and
trans parts anyways television actually
can also be a little bit better than
film in this regard because as a medium
television is more open to rolling the
dice on up-and-comers and new faces
though again that often depends on how
much money is being spent on the thing
rule of thumb is the more money is at
play the less likely it is
for an unknown to get cast and there's a
lot more money thrown about with felts
part to how auditions were most
supposedly open auditions are still
based around a standardized type that is
being cast for it's actually where the
term typecasting comes from in case you
ever wondered these type guidelines are
given to casting directors and sent out
to agents and usually consist of at the
least a gender and age range but
frequently will also include body type
height weight skin tone or even hair
color guidelines not to mention
potentially specific skills they might
have casting directors some of them will
stick more straight strictly to
guidelines than others but none of them
are gonna stray too far off more than
one or two requirements if they have any
intention of keeping their job now to be
clear I am NOT saying it's automatically
a bad thing to cast for a type directors
with a proper plan should know what they
want and if they don't streamline the
casting process it will take forever
what I'm trying to bring the cross is
the fact that even when a part is
auditioned for the vast majority of
potential actors won't even get an
audition slot because they don't meet
the type on the call sheet every now and
then you get an aggressive casting agent
with some pull who muscles in and out of
the box client into the audition room
but an actors more likely to get struck
by lightning than to have that happen to
them so at best the audition process
finds the best actor for the role out of
the heavily narrowed field of people who
fit the type that the director asked for
and even if you fit the type auditions
are no joke and they can be extremely
nerve-racking and it really shouldn't be
surprising that many aspiring actors
will just throw their hands up and say
heck with it I'll just make my own movie
if that sounds like you then you're
gonna want some guy
on how to make professional level films
with fewer resources and smaller budgets
and such guidance can be found at skills
share skill share is a terrific resource
and they are also the generous sponsor
of today's video skill share is an
online learning community with classes
that cover dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills a Premium
Membership is less than $10 per month
for an annual subscription when it comes
to film classes there are offerings
which cover pretty much every aspect
there's cinematography editing they even
have one on documentary filmmaking but
if you'd like a place to start I would
recommend low-budget filmmaking from
award-winning short film maker Maddy
brown skill share is the perfect place
to keep you learning and thriving
whether you are looking to fuel your
creativity your career or just your
curiosity and because Skillshare is
sponsoring this video you can sign up
using the link in the description and
get a 2 month free trial of the premium
service and of course they offer much
more than fill classes so at the very
least consider checking them out see if
there's anything that might appeal to
you but really the fact that auditions
are type restricted and not as open as
folks think isn't even the issue in the
instances where I've seen the best for
the role argument used it doesn't matter
how open the casting process is or isn't
because for mainstream films with
multi-million dollar budgets and studio
backing even the more artsy Oscar bait
types there usually isn't an audition
process at all part 3 when there's no
audition which is most of the time let's
take a look at a few examples where
trans characters were played by sis
actors with the understanding that I am
only talking about the casting process
that was used and I am not passing
judgment on how well the actors
performed in the roles or the quality of
the film's overall I really want people
to keep that
mind even though I know plenty of folks
will ignore my saying that additionally
I'm going to largely focus on relatively
recent films mostly these are going to
be from the last decade or so because
even though this casting trend isn't
actually that recent the older film is
the harder it is to find reliable
information about how the casting
process went down and also these are in
absolutely no particular order to get it
out of the way let's start with the film
and the casting that even started me
talking about this topic in the first
place over a year ago
Scarlett Johansson being cast to play a
trans man in a real life inspired film
that was to be called rub-and-tug
she was brought onto the project along
with director Rupert Sanders who she'd
worked with previously on the ghost in
the shell' the live-action version the
two of them apparently rather enjoyed
working together and they were simply
attached to the project
now this film actually didn't end up
getting made but we'll come back to that
just stick a pen the point is there was
no audition process no one else besides
Johansson was considered now let's talk
about the Danish girl also based on a
real-life figure this film actually
bounced around for a while before it
eventually got made but from what I
could find at no point were they holding
auditions for the lead role originally
Nicole Kidman was attached under a
director who ultimately left the project
and then eventually she also moved on
when the director who actually got it
made Tom Hooper came on board he said
that Eddie Redmayne was in his mind from
the first time he read the script
so Redmayne only had to say yes and
didn't audition against anyone else the
film Albert Nobbs is a bit of a curious
case because star Glenn Close had
actually played the role in a staged
version of that exact same story all the
way back in 1982
and she then spent ages trying to get a
film adaptation off the ground so first
of all props to her for persistence and
obviously since she was at the heart of
it being made in the first place nobody
else was ever in contention for the part
then there's the film trans America
which actually gives us our first
deviation from this pattern according to
transgender actress
Alexandra Billings she was actually cast
in the lead role only to receive a phone
call 24 hours later telling her they
couldn't use her because they needed a
recognizable name the film ultimately
was made with Felicity Huffman who
Billings did praise for her work so
there doesn't seem to be any bad blood
there this story about the casting
process didn't come out until some years
later and I'll admit I couldn't find a
ton of corroboration for it but I also
couldn't find any of the people involved
in the film disputing this story either
so let's actually hop back to the 90s
and talk about Priscilla Queen of the
desert I was actually surprised how much
I could find on the casting process of
this film but you know getting given its
age and nearly indeed status but that
kind of happens with cult classics way
more information gets compiled and you
would otherwise expect so if you don't
know this film it's about drag
performers and that is not the same
thing as being transgender but one of
the core three cast is a transgender
woman the character is rather the
character named Bernadette is played by
Terence Stamp he wasn't the first choice
for the role and the filmmakers
considered an approached Tony Curtis
John Cleese and Tim Curry before finally
landing on stamp despite going through
multiple options none of these men had
to audition and only sis men were ever
considered or offered the part it
suddenly come closer to the present and
touch on Dallas buyers club originally
Hilary Swank was in talks to play the
part of a trans woman she ultimately
did not sign on after Swank Gael Garcia
Bernal was in negotiations for the part
though it would ultimately go to Jared
Leto again despite multiple people being
considered none of them had to actually
audition it was always just down to the
negotiation process and who ended up
saying yes since I mentioned Hillary
Swank let's actually talk about a truly
indie film so we can have an instance
where there was an actual lengthy
audition process boys don't cry
was the movie that puts Swank on the map
and she was cast as a trans man after
writer director Kimberly piers
auditioned hundreds of potential actors
and wasn't happy with what she was
finding something similar actually
happened with The Crying Game Wow it
doesn't appear that trans woman were
being looked at for the role of dil
director Neil Jordan did clash with
producers because he insisted on finding
a passable androgynous male while the
producers felt that a woman would have
to be cast because no man would ever be
convincing Jay Davidson who had no prior
acting experience was discovered at a
rap party and encouraged to audition so
yes when the project is small enough
auditions do happen these two instances
might sound like some lovely Cinderella
stories in a way I suppose the kind of
are but understand that the films were
held up due to lengthy casting processes
and in the case of boys don't cry it
almost didn't happen at all because
Pearce was on the verge of giving up the
search after nearly four years of
looking and that is exactly why there
aren't open casting processes for lead
roles part four does TV do it better
this is a slight divergence that I feel
it should be touched on while we're here
I mentioned actually at the top that TV
has a bit more leeway than films when it
comes to giving a shot to new faces and
that does work in the mediums favor when
it comes to casting trans characters
broadly speaking it's been way ahead of
film when it comes to trans actors
playing trans characters
unfortunately because TV production
doesn't get the same obsessive level of
attention paid to it in its development
process I had a much harder time
tracking down how the casting process
went for well basically for any of the
shows I'm about to bring up since I
can't be certain about what was done
with auditions if there were any I will
try to keep this section snappy and
avoid too much speculation about what
may or may not have happened if I can
help it so let's do a quick ish rundown
of trans characters in notable TV roles
the obvious one to bring up is trans
actress Laverne Cox in her breakout role
as a trans woman in a women's prison in
orange is the new black now Cox also
played a trans woman on the show doubt
and will be doing so again on the
upcoming show inventing Anna Orana
I'm not sure how they're pronouncing
that but let's do you think Cox is all
there is will rapid-fire the trans
actors playing trans characters on major
shows from the last eye within the last
decade or so
so sense8 had Jamie Clayton Dirty Sexy
Money at Candis Cayne the Fosters
brought us Tom Phelan euphoria has
hunter Schaefer and Supergirl has Nicole
Mane's all of these are trans actors
playing openly trans characters or at
least acknowledge trans characters this
isn't always the case though as another
prominent example is Rebecca romaine
playing a trans woman on the show Ugly
Betty however from what I could find
that
since very much appears to be the
exception rather than the rule which is
pretty much the inverse of what we saw
in films so given that of the prominent
examples that I found from the last
decade or so even with my very limited
research abilities only one featured a
syst actor playing a trans character and
in that instance the actor in question
was a big name by TV standards so with
that you might be led to conclude that
TV has pretty much just dunked on movies
across the board on this issue but hold
on there because there is a hitch TV may
be better about casting trans actors in
trans roles but there is a commonality
among all the characters that I've just
talked about that I think is important
note they are all either supporting
characters or are pardon of of an
ensemble in a show that has no single
lead character none of them are the
focus of the series and that's one area
where movies have the advantage right
now because it's in film that we can
find stories about trans people instead
of stories that only feature trans
people now I see some of you in the back
you're raising your hand pointing out
the one notable show that I left off the
list yes I was saving it and we're
getting to it now the one prominent
instance of television having a
transgender character in a lead that I
could find was Amazon Prime's
transparent which start sis male actor
Jeffrey Tambor who like Rebecca Romain
is a big name by TV standards playing a
trans woman transitioning late in life
or at least it did star him until he was
let go over harassment allegations and
what was supposed to be the fifth season
of the show was instead turned into a
single film length episode in which
Tambor himself did not appear but my
point is the one instance again that I
could find where the show can be said to
be truly about a trans character as far
as the TV landscape goes and look at
that we're right
back to where we were on films this
actor relatively big name for the role
and it's also one of the only instances
where I could track down the casting and
huh apparently the creator had him in
mind from the beginning so no audition
process hope you didn't pay yourself in
the back too hard earlier there TV
you've still got work to do but hey
since I brought it up let's jump on back
to film and talk about part 5 the need
for a name you've probably already
picked up on the recurrent theme of film
casting not having an open audition
process because the role needs a name
actor in order for the project to secure
financing and there really aren't trans
actors with the box-office clout to get
a film made on the strength of their
name we actually saw that with the
production of rub-and-tug I told you we
took come back to that because when
Scarlett Johansson left the finding man
Sears also left as well because they
signed on for a Scarlett Johansson movie
and they actually didn't care all that
much about the story being told and
that's just the business reality I'm not
gonna pretend otherwise the problem is
it becomes a recursive self-perpetuating
loop where trans actors don't kick ass
and lead roles because their name isn't
big enough but their name will never get
big enough because they don't get cast
and lead roles and round and round
around we go but we may have actually
reached a point at this stage that we're
casting a syst
actor in the trans role goes down so
badly with the target audience for these
types of movies that's not worth doing
that anymore which puts us at something
of a crossroads because either we're
going to start seeing more appropriate
casting or we're going to simply stop
seeing these sorts of stories being made
on film by anyone other than small indie
productions a bit like it was way back
in the 90s and if I were to guess I
suspect what we'll see is a period of
fewer films with trans lead characters
at least as far as studio backed films
go but more trans characters being
played by trans actors and supporting
roles like we're already seeing on TV
and hopefully those actors will start
get better recognized so that finding in
Sears might be comfortable casting them
as leads this still wouldn't really be
ideal because it's a process that's
likely to take a few years cycle through
but it would at least be going in a
better direction part six closing
thoughts
honestly the entire notion of best for
the role isn't just false when it comes
to this kind of casting its false in
virtually every case of casting a major
part whoever ends up in almost any given
role might well be the person the
director believes to be the best for the
part but 99% of the time that belief
does not get tested by putting that
person through an audition process yes
you can cite me instances where that
happened but they're very rare and you
need to recognize that so to treat the
best person was cast as some kind of
objective fact would be like declaring
the winner of the Boston Marathon but
never actually making that person
compete against other people in the darn
thing so we can add this topic to my
collection of videos that I get to now
just link wherever I see arguments
brought up in the comments I can file it
right alongside my video on
representation and the Chinese box
office and Bill Potts
as the agenda pushing Doctor Who
companion it's just nice not to have to
type out these arguments and full
anymore honestly I mean these videos are
really just about making my life easier
[Music]
thank you for watching and for making it
all the way through if you like what
you've seen here I hope that you will
consider supporting me on patreon it
helps keep the lights on and keep this
whole thing going you can also always
like share subscribe and of course
comment because I do very sincerely love
to hear your thoughts as long as they're
expressed politely thanks again to
Skillshare don't forget to check out the
offer in the description thanks to the
Green Mountain cabaret for standing in
line for my silly visual and thanks to
the people whose names you're now seeing
for their continued patronage you can
join them a help support the channel as
well as check out my other merch social
media accounts all the stuffs down in
the description but also you don't have
to do any of that because at the end of
the day you're the council I'm only
running the meetings and until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]